sao paulo les vins quartier qui compte
le plus grand nombre de décès causés par
le coville se trouvent dans les zones
périphériques de la commune comme à
brazil andia à 15 km du centre ville
avec près de 300 morts ce territoire
devenu tristement célèbre pour son
record de victimes du coronavirus la
perte de revenus également en raison de
la crise sanitaire aggravent la
situation des habitants nombreux ici
sont ceux qui dépendent de l'économie
informelle et ne dispose pas de contrat
de travail le gouverneur de l'état de
sao paulo a donc autorisé depuis le 1er
juin la réouverture de plusieurs
services non essentiels de la ville je
trouve que l'ouverture des commerces et
précoce car les courbes de décès et de
cas de contamination n'ont pas cessé de
monter surtout dans les périphéries où
on manque parfois d'information les gens
ne croient pas que le virus soit aussi
mortelle sans parler du fait que
beaucoup d'habitants ici sont obligés
d'aller travailler pour avoir de quoi
manger tout simplement dans les favelas
ce et d'autres quartiers défavorisés
plusieurs produits d'hygiène sont
difficiles à se procurer il isolement
social est impossible à respecter
près de 40 % de la population
brésilienne n'a pas accès aux services
sanitaires de base notamment l'eau
potable dans de telles conditions le
simple fait de se laver est inconcevable
l'hôpital de brazil ando est en travaux
depuis plus de 14 ans rapidement
transformée en hôpital de campagne
il manque cruellement de moyens les
travaux ont été mises à l'arrêt il ya 4
ans car la mairie disait ne pas avoir
assez d'argent ils l'ont donc transformé
en hôpital de campagne mais il n'y a que
20 lits en unité de soins intensifs
c'est clairement une question de
négligence de la part des politiques
brasil en dia est un des quartiers
périphériques qui souffrent le plus au
brésil surtout quand il s'agit de santé
publique
au brésil plus de 13 millions de
personnes habitent dans les favelas face
à l'épidémie ces quartiers populaires
aux ruelles exigu sont des bombes à
retardement
l'épidémie continue de sévir dans le
pays qui compte plus de cinquante sept
mille décès le bilan le plus meurtrier
sur la planète après les états unis